okay all set now thank you
as chair of the house ways and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the hospital 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session on
on senate bills
please note there's no physical location
for members can anyone hear me
yes
okay i'll continue please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe
and listen contemporariously to this
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available on
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies the
health schools and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600
or email hcs at
u lake.state.nh.us in the event the
public is unable to access this meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
which is christine
christina dyer who's a committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
that president please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
okay representative bernstein would you
call the rolls
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you it is may the 4th
2021 it's 9 33 a.m
we'll begin roll call with
representative patrick obrami
yes uh thank you i'm here in stratham
alone thank you representative mary
griffin
representative jordan owerry and may the
fourth be with you
okay here we have holland alone or at
home the wife is in the house someplace
thank you good morning representative
ober
here in hudson with the six cats and for
the chairman
i have a dentist appointment at 12. i'll
be leaving a little early
noted representative doucette good
morning mr clerk
home alone my uh office in salem
good morning uh your clerk is alan
burstein i'm in nottingham new hampshire
in my home office by myself
representative elliott
i'm here in salem new hampshire at my
daughter's house
and i can't wait for my wife to come
home very good
representative jeaninian home in my
home office in salem and my wife is
somewhere in the house
back on the mainland representative
herschel nunes
good morning mr clark thank you very
much it's good to be back
i am home alone in pelham representative
tim baxter
representative snowsbury good morning
home alone in charlestown
good morning representative tutor good
morning
home alone in northwood representative
morning uh home alone good morning
representative ames
i'm here in jeffrey in my home office
alone representative
southworth home in dover alone
representative malloy alone greenland
um to my home representative thomas
schamberg
good morning representative burst gene
i'm in new london be getting in my truck
very shortly
heading back to wilmington
representative tucker
i'm home alone in
randolph did you have to check your
notes
for that i was just making sure i wasn't
muted
representative gomarlo uh i'm in swansea
alone
representative laughman representative
gorg
representative hacken phillips morning i
am alone here in my office in concord
representative murphy
uh good morning i am alone in my home
office in hanover good morning
and our chairman representative norman
major good morning i'm in my home in
plasto and my wife is in the house
mr chair there are 20 members present
four
are not present
thank you representative bernstein
this morning we have a work session on
seven
bills that we have heard
and i'm going to have to leave by 11
o'clock
and representative romney will take over
at that point in time
we'll start off with senate bill
22 dash fn
senate bill 22-fn relative to the sale
of lucky seven
tickets and these work sessions this
morning
is to identify do we have any any
further questions or
more information that we need on any one
of these
senate bills now is the time to bring
that out
and so that we'll have the time to if we
need to
bring somebody else and answer questions
so does anybody have any issues or
questions
on senate bill 22 or additional
information they need
in order to make a determination we will
not be
executing today we will be exacting
these bills next tuesday
any questions norm yes
i got a call from uh tyler clark um
about section three um
he thinks we need to change the wording
a little bit um
if tyler is on the call if he's on the
zoom
i'd like him to explain it he was going
to send me some language but i haven't
seen it
jen is here would you let him in
i just did you'll be here in a second
okay
good morning mr chairman can you hear me
i can hear your tyler
yes just to yes i can hear you guys uh
just to address representative abrami's
uh concern here i
happen to send it to your legislative
email but i know there's a lot going on
so it might have gotten lost
in the kirkbuffle but section three uh
as i read it right now it does mandate
that a
charity has to purchase a 25 cent ticket
where a one dollar ticket
is sold um you know as i told
representative abrami
the 25 cent ticket at least for our
business diamond distributors and
we sell paper
lucky seven tickets to bingo's in
charities
uh that's one of our least selling
products so we find it kind of unfair
to mandate that they have to purchase a
product that
you know we don't sell a lot of and they
probably don't have many consumers
who are players who purchase these uh
tickets
uh there is a small market for 25 cent
but we don't believe that it should be
mandated so i have some language that
just states you know the price of a
ticket shall not exceed a dollar
and then it strikes the language stating
that it they must
shall sell a 25 cent ticket where a
dollar ticket is sold
and i know that language of mandating
that a
where a dollar ticket is sold a 50 cent
ticket must also be sold as part of the
uh compromise from last year's
legislation that
created the dollar ticket so i did not
touch that language i simply uh in the
language that i proposed or will i'll
send it to the committee
destruct the section that said we shall
sell 25 cents
questions from the committee
representative
you're muted
you're muted sorry
i think that the phone in attendees is
mary griffin and i
ask that she'd be allowed to participate
if so
but also on
i wanted to
to contest the the
the other parts of the bill and i don't
know does that mean
on just bringing in
and amendment to i think it's delete
both of them i thought we were going to
discuss all this stuff again um
but they do uh complete
turning these machines into
semi-slot machines and allow them
on in another bill to go into
just about every place in new hampshire
that might
possibly be able to take them
and and i
i know this may be a losing argument at
this point
but um turning ourselves into oregon
doesn't seem like a great idea
thank you
thank you representative uh
representative romney uh yeah thank you
mr chair
so i'll let me take a look at the
language that uh
tyler is talking about and then uh i may
just do open amendment but
susan if you representative army if you
want to do an amendment
uh i'll share this with you and you may
also want to incorporate it into your
amendment
yes yes i would like to incorporate the
25 cent part
and i think representative griffin is in
favor of that too but if that is her i
think
it would be nice if she could be brought
in thank you
let's see i allowed that person
to speak so if it is mary maybe she can
um
okay the one with the phone ending zero
eight nine yes identify yourself
star six i believe
christina correct me if i'm wrong about
that star six to talk
i believe that's correct um my
understanding is that
um representative griffin's ends in zero
um
six uh five nine nine five nine is what
i believe it is
yes i don't think it's her oh
mr chair christine is on for another a
different bill
mr chair okay
um okay so we didn't find
the identity of that 089
no no and again
representative elmi
was what was your position on the 25
cent ticket
i'm i'm in favor of making it optional i
realized i mean 25 cents
was more money when it was put in than
it is now
it's kind of like having the penny
auntie bingo that
that i know about right
and and the bill as written right now
says the organization shall offer 25
and 50 tickets for sale and so
and so you agree with the amendment
i agree with that amendment i just don't
like sections one and two
okay all right
all right
thank you um
so i think uh mr clark is still
um available to answer questions
mr clark
yes i'm still here representative ames
chairman
um yeah i my understanding is that you
oppose the bill
and um that that relates to
the provision that makes the
availability of paper
tickets is that the right word for paper
results uh
um optional is that correct
correct uh diamond distributors opposes
section one
into the bill okay uh so
on that uh
option i'm i'm wondering if you have
information or your
perspective on what uh
eliminating that uh
that paper requirement does in terms of
the
speed of betting that's enabled by the
machine
how frequently can bets be made with or
without the paper option
i don't have any updated information as
to how fast the ticket
prints but i do know that through rule
making
last summer the speed of play on these
machines
was increased so it was previously five
seconds
a spin and now it is uh i think it was
moved to two and a half but
realistically it's a three
is my understanding of how fast these
machines play so it's every three
seconds
and i think the printing may be able to
keep up
with that but there could be somebody
else here who is more
in tune with how these machines function
these days that could probably answer
that
but my understanding is they're set at
three seconds now or they have
through rules they can be set at three
seconds
okay well thank you that's very very
helpful to have that three seconds
in the record i'm glad to know that
do we have anybody from the lottery
uh is john conforty one of the lottery
people
yes i can let him in i have to be raised
his hand
oh christina did christine is our um
are jennifer for today oh i'm sorry
i confuse it with somebody else that's
going to be speaking later okay sorry
good morning mr chairman john conforti
uh chief compliance officer for the new
hampshire lottery i'm happy to answer
any questions that i can do you have any
information on how fast
read-a-play could be for machines that
would be
dispensing my understanding
is that the um the timing as as was
indicated is set by rules and
that the um the printing mechanism is
not
going to be uh a determining factor in
how
fast the the game play uh would be
allowed
now is there
anything that is in roles now
or have they thought of anything
the timing that they would incorporate
if this passes
uh representative major i don't believe
that we've
had any discussions about um how we
would
um address any of these changes and
rules other than
um obviously making sure that the rules
conform to the to the change regarding
deal size
and you know that the payment would be
based on the 3 500 tickets as opposed to
the
um as opposed to one deal
um but i don't believe that we are
anticipating
um other rule changes other than
um specifically aligning the rules with
the new statutory language
right and there's no statutory language
that suggests how much how smoothly
these could be
i don't believe that the timing of the
machines is addressed in statute
okay
any further questions representative
alani followed by ruxin ames
oh no i'm not on anymore
sorry thank you thank you mr chairman
uh these machines
were approved reluctantly by
our committee as dispensing machines
on during the hearing on
charlie told us that they don't dispense
they have been converted because
we didn't nail down every little piece
of the language of how these machines
work
they have been converted into
uh video
lottery machines essentially on
by putting out on
the the result on the
monitor making it unnecessary to have
look at a ticket so you can do it a lot
faster
when you when it was a dispensing
machine which is what we thought we were
approving
on the ticket drop down you had to pick
up the ticket and look at it
so there was considerably more time
involved now that they've eliminated
that by allowing it to be on the monitor
on the the debate that we're having
essentially is whether we are going to
just sanction in law what is already
been done by the lottery commission
and i just want to object thank you
representative elliot followed by
representative doucet
and abram
i have a question for mr clark uh is it
my understanding that you were opposed
to the 25 cent and the 50
ticket because and i asked that question
because
in most of the casinos that i've been to
um even have penny machines
so my understanding or of
opinion is that this is for the poor
people
who like to gamble uh so
i i don't understand why you want to
eliminate
uh the 25 cent or 50 cent
ticket or am i misunderstanding you sir
thank you for the question
representative elliott um
just to clarify there might be a slight
misunderstanding
we do not oppose a 50 cent or
uh the dollar ticket at this point it's
a point in time and you know we
absolutely support
bringing back the 25 cent ticket we
think it was a
a oversight
last year you know when the language was
drafted for the dollar ticket
um that we accidentally removed the 25
cent ticket and i
you know we we do sell or we did sell 25
cent tickets just not many of them
we don't sell any dollar tickets uh we
sell all 50 cent tickets to bingo's
in fraternal organizations so that they
can sell them
at their bingo or in their fraternal
hall
thank you for that clarification
okay when i look at the screen it's
different than the participants
so i'm going to use the participant list
the next one is fed dessert
representative
good morning uh just informational for
you mr chairman i was on the phone with
representative griffin
and uh she is unable to attend today
just
wanted to confirm that to you when i
told her i would
thank you representative
representative romney yes
uh just just a point of uh of
information for the committee
the there are such there is such a thing
as dispensing machines as well
that dispense the old-fashioned uh uh
tickets a lot of fraternal
halls have those because they don't want
somebody walking around selling the
tickets so they just go to the machine
and they can
dispense as many of the of the true the
old-fashioned lucky seven
pull tabs as they want so those still
exist
and uh representative amy's talking
about the
the electronic version of that the
electronic uh
version of lucky seven thank you
uh representative tucker yes i would
very much
like uh to know what representative
griffin
thinks of this since we
wanted to get information today as to
different opinions and perhaps someone
could be delegated to
talk with her and
find out her opinion before it comes up
again
so we're ready to understand she's sort
of the expert
i have uh been
impressed with her ability to be
persuasive too and
and to protect our seniors yeah
exactly but uh i think this is very
important i think that uh
representative almy has brought up some
concerning uh points and
i'm now conflicted as to how i uh
understand this these issues and it's
getting murkier
by the minute and so uh
i'd like our expert to speak up
sex can you check with uh representative
[Music]
i will do so uh again mr chair like she
said she's unavailable to
uh speak to the group today and um
reach out i'll ever reach out to you
directly mr jammer yeah
okay thank you thank you
that's an thank you uh
i called her up last night because i
wanted to know what she thought of these
things
i discovered she has not seen any of
these bills
they are not sending them to her and
obviously she can't
get them herself um
so i tried to read her
two of them and
that is obviously very difficult for
someone who's 96 years old
she did say that
on that she
disagreed that she agreed with uh
mr clark's idea on the 25
ticket on but
that she didn't want to see
her low-income seniors
on lose all of their money in
in machine gaming
and she didn't put it quite that way but
but that she was worried about these
machines going to the electronic side
and i
i wish she'd be able to uh she did last
night
tell me that she was going to be on
today
so mr chairman yes
i'm not going to put words in in the
representative's
mouth i spoke to her not five minutes
ago and she didn't
make a definitive uh decision as to
where she stands on this and like i said
um short of her speaking directly to you
or to this committee
um i would caution others to do the same
thing
so uh yes i will call her right now and
have her uh get a hold of you
mr chan but she's uh she's not well this
morning
well maybe that would be very good
because i was just trying to say that so
that you could see that there was
a debate in her mind at this point at
least
this is going to be further discussed
next tuesday
and uh we'll give representative griffin
some time and we'll check with
her
is there anything else new on senate
bill 22
then
mr chairman um john conforty seems to
have his hand up
oh from the lottery
john thank you representative major
i just uh wanted to make a quick point
of clarification
um that to to add to your discussion
um the electronic lucky seven machines
do
dispense tickets currently um i
i don't know i know representative alan
indicated that
um director mcintyre uh said that they
they don't i think as a practical matter
players
view the results on the video screen
currently
but i do want just for a point of
clarification as you're
as you're looking at this bill each of
those machines does
dispense a paper ticket
um it's just that as a practical matter
that the players tend to ignore those
tickets as they're dispensed
thank you that's good information
okay for those that have an amendment
please get that amendment out this week
to all the committee members
so they have it to go over when we meet
next tuesday
i would like to get this exact next
tuesday
okay mr chairman yes
could i just ask uh lottery to do one
thing which is to find
us whether there is anything in
the rsas that
allowed them to start showing the result
on the video monitor
or whether we're just putting it in
post-facto
did you get that yes
i did i we will um send a response to
representative almi
and the rest of the um committee
thank you
all right
next senate bill
is senate bill 27 relative to the sale
of lucky seven tickets again
and again we don't have anybody signed
up
to add any further information so i
asked the committee members what
questions remain
to be answered or additional information
that you have
i know that an amendment has been
brought forth by representative alame so
i don't
i'm representative bromley i'm sorry
about that so what
why don't you represent abroad
explain what your proposed amendment is
okay uh charlie mcintyre uh thank you mr
chair charlie mcintyre asked me to file
this amendment
uh he feels that there occasionally will
be an exception to the rule
as to what constitutes a charity that's
eligible
uh and i think this got sent to
everybody
uh and uh i
i'd like uh mr conforti to speak to it
but also
um okay the amendment
is amendment number 2021-12368
right and then there's also a lisa allen
uh who's is an example of an
organization that would benefit from
this
amendment so if john is uh uh
john is still on uh maybe he can explain
uh the reason for the the amendment
john well thank you mr chairman thank
you representative abrami yes
um we had requested uh that
representative abrami
uh make this amendment um there are
um isolated incidents where we have
charities um that are bona fide
charities doing
uh work in uh new hampshire um
that would um that meet the
the spirit um and purpose of the statute
but do not check all the boxes
um with regard to um rep
um either being registered with the
secretary of state as a non-profit or
with the attorney general's office
um for one reason or another um i
believe that feed new hampshire is
uh on and can address their specific
um circumstances um uh
more directly but um there are there are
circumstances where
um for example a charity is an arm of a
for-profit company and through oversight
it hasn't been separated into a separate
non-profit
um or it hasn't registered in time
and certainly what we have found is
there
are worthy charities um who
meet the requirements of
doing non-profit work doing charitable
work in the state
they are not fly-by-night operations
they are well established
but their filing has not uh been at the
secretary of state
for the required amount of time um or
there is some other
very minor technical defect which
prevents them from being licensed as a
charitable
uh as a charity for gaming purposes
so the intent of this amendment was to
provide a mechanism for those very few
circumstances um where an
organization can demonstrate that they
are
a an established charity doing
charitable work here in new hampshire
that the funds from charitable gaming
would remain within the state
um and that there was a there's a
justifiable reason why they're not able
to meet one of the technical
requirements
of the statute we these are so
infrequent that we didn't feel that a
change of the um definitional
requirements was
appropriate but that there should be
some mechanism
to allow for these these one-offs um
uh to to participate in charitable
gambling
and john you there was it
might be here
yes i believe there's a representative
from the feed new hampshire
um who um has we've worked with
um and is a great example of um of this
circumstance
mr chair it's uh mr chair it's lisa
allen surname
it's host lisa allen
and i see her down the bottom of the
screen that she's
i think she's already in yes she has
permission to talk
okay fine so
before we go to susan
i mean to represent elmie go ahead and
lisa
hello my name is lisa allen good morning
mr chairman and all and thank you for
taking the time to hear
to hear us today i'm the board chair for
great new hampshire restaurants
charitable trust which we lovingly call
feednh.org
we are registered with the director of
charitable trust in new hampshire
and we file an annual report with this
office
and we are also our tax-exempt 501 c 3
with the irs
in the last six years we've donated over
700 thousand dollars to
dozens of new hampshire charitable
organizations
serving new hampshire's families elderly
education
and disadvantage currently the way the
rule is written
we are not eligible to receive
gay charitable gaming donations because
although we are registered with the
director of charitable trust
we are not registered as a charitable
organization with the state mostly
actually all in part because of the way
we are set up
the trust is set up with three trustees
and we have a board of nine community
members who serve
to make decisions about um how we
raise funds as well as how we disperse
funds
if we were feeding h.org
is a charitable arm of a
for-profit company by registering
with the state as a charitable
organization
that would force us to have
basically turn over the control
of our trust that we built to
serve what our customers our employees
the family's elderly education and
disadvantage
and we would have to have five
non-at least five board
members that would control this
charitable trust if we were to set it up
that way
um so really that's it
i mean this simple language change that
just says as long as we're registered
with the director
of charitable trust in new hampshire and
our filings are up to date
and we are at 501c3 which we check all
of those boxes
and we're not required to
change the way we have set up our trust
to serve
our communities um we would be eligible
for this gaming
we're currently gaming donations where
currently we are not
you lisa uh questions for lisa
uh represent almi followed by
representative romney
uh mine is not a question for lisa
on i understand and
am okay with the amendment just not with
dependency
on gaming okay thank you uh
representative brown
actually um my hand was up from before
i'm all set okay
representative ames
yeah thank you um i just want to be
clear
on what this amendment does um
and i i'm handicapped because i don't
seem to have
the statute in front of my existing
statute but uh
but it's reassuring to to know that your
organization is a 501c3
and the problem you're having in
countering is
the registration requirement with the
attorney general's office there's some
variation there my question
to you is if this amendment goes through
would the requirement that um
the organization your organization
would still have to demonstrate
compliance with
the federal rules regarding
i don't quite know how to say this the
charitable organization rules that lead
to
your sighting 501c3 as a
as a as one of the criteria
um we are more than happy to
and able to um
sustain all of our current
uh i i'm kind of trying to search for
words like you are but all the filings
that we have to do
for both with the charitable trust
division of new hampshire as well as the
irs we are
current with that and more than happy to
continue being current with that i'm not
sure if that is exactly what you are
asking
um we because because it's an
arm of a for-profit business we do
put a great deal of effort into
the guarding any conflict of interest
so we have separate attorneys for
this charitable trust we have separate
accountants for the charitable trust
um we we do all of our
diligence to ensure that there's not
ever any question that the money is
being used for anything
but what we wanted it to be used for
which is to serve
other new hampshire charitable
organizations we're basically a
fundraising
machine for all these organizations in
new hampshire
and it allows we had a gaming
a gaming organization reach out to us
wanting to donate to us and then sort of
hit a brick wall and
unable to donate to us because of the
way this
rule is currently written
okay okay thank you thank you uh follow
up
i guess it's not really a follow-up i
think that
it would be helpful to have lottery uh
confirm
what requirement would would apply
if this amendment were adopted uh
with specific reference to 501 c
3 and it's uh and the the group of 501c
um provisions that organizations right
now have to
um demonstrate that they
made they comply with
john thank you for the question
representative
so r the intent of this
um is um that it's a waiver provision
and they would the um anyone who's
applying for a waiver
um would need to demonstrate that they
are still organized for a charitable
purpose
um obviously 5 501 c 3 designation or
any of the other 501c designations would
be
probably important evidence of that it's
not specifically called out
in the amendment but our expectation
would be that we wouldn't grant a waiver
uh that that that anyone who's seeking a
waiver is
likely to um to have those 501c3
um requirements uh
be complying with those currently and
would continue to
um again this is really to address
issues where
the nature of the charity is such that
um
they're they're not either currently
registered with the secretary of state
as a non-profit
or cannot as as feed new hampshire as
has indicated
thank you john are you all set
representing
for the moment i i need to look i i i
as i said i was handicapped i don't have
the statute right in front of me i want
to look closely at this and
if um and be satisfied that
that the allowance for a waiver doesn't
reach into provisions that should under
no circumstances be waived
and we'll be addressing this
bill again next one on a tuesday
all right we have
representative did you raise your hand
again
yes i did i'd been i'd planned on
speaking when we
went off to the amendment i mean i
planned on speaking about something else
two things actually on
both of them require more information
or rather one of them does that is we
were going to we
asked at the first meeting i believe
what are all of these c's 501 c's
we still don't have a list of on maybe
from charitable trusts i don't know who
would give it to us
of what is comprised
by c4 which i know has
a lot of political organizations in it
on
c 8 7 8
10 and 19.
and i also would point out this is
charitable
gaming on expanding it to this
extent would make it a lot
harder unless we're going to have um
[Music]
thought parlors like the one that's
going to be in lebanon everywhere in the
state
but that would probably help uh it would
be considerably harder for any charity
to get
get a slot on
and my other question
but i would like to get a list of what
kinds of organizations in somewhat more
detail
than just this is a civic organization
on
are in these different categories
and the other question is about
uh section five which was added on
is is just about bingo and it seems to
contradict
part of the bill we just discussed
it says that there is a
deal means a single game of uncirculated
lucky seven tickets bearing a serial
number
so i think we need to discuss that too
thank you okay
representative tucker you had your hand
up i took it down
because we seem to have moved on i see
that representative
again phillips's hand is up
representing hacks and fellows
good morning i just was gonna follow up
on representative almi's question
about the irs codes that are listed
on page uh i guess that's
two of the bill or paragraph 15 of the
bill
so if i'm looking at the irc code
it's us code 26 us code 501
section c and if you
look to the definitions section
subsection four are social welfare
um organizations so
um like she was mentioning that's a
pretty wide definition
of what that is um but if you look at
the code it does narrow it a bit down
um specifically civic leagues or
organizations
not organized for profit but operated
exclusively for the promotion of social
welfare
or local associations of employees the
member of which
a membership of which is limited to the
employees of a designated person or
persons in a particular municipality and
the net earnings of which are devoted
exclusively
to charitable educational or
recreational purposes
um subsection
c7 is uh
clubs organized for pleasure recreation
and other non-profitable purposes
substantially all of the activities for
which
are for such purposes and no part of the
net earnings
of which in yours to the benefit of any
private shareholder
subsection c 8
are fraternal beneficiary societies
orders or associations
operating either under the lodge system
for an exclusive benefit of the members
of a fraternity itself
under the lodge system or providing for
the payment of life
sick accident and other benefits to the
members of such society
order or association or their dependents
uh subsection c10
is a domestic fraternal society order or
association
operating under the lodge system um but
it would have either the net earnings of
which are devoted exclusively to
religious
charitable scientific literary
educational and fraternal purposes
and uh or oh no i'm sorry it's a it's an
and so it would have to be both
qualifications
and which do not provide for payment of
life sick
accident or other benefits
um subsection c19
is uh
is that page down here it's a post or
organization of past or present members
of the armed forces of the united states
so think uh vfw or another auxiliary
unit
or it's a trust or foundation for any
post or
such organization we'd have to be
organize the united states
and have at least 75 percent of the
members of which
our past or present members of the armed
forces of the united states and
substantially all of the other members
of which are individuals who are cadets
spouses widows widowers ancestors lineal
descendants etc
and have no part of the net earnings
which adheres to the benefit of a
private shareholder individual
i think the important thing for the
committee to consider is that there are
several other subsections
of the irs uh s code 501
subsection c that are not included and i
think this goes back to you know
previous discussions we've had
about you know this area of the the code
you know there are other organizations
that are
excluded so for instance like teachers
unions
cemetery companies trusts
um there are um
you know other
organizations in the sub chapter who
are organized in such a way to benefit
those members
um internally and i'm not sure that it's
um
the purpose of providing a charitable
you know donation or or fund or
contribution to these
501cs is
equal among the subsection 501c
subsections so i just think it's worth
considering
obviously everyone will have their own
opinions about
how and which you know organizations are
worthy of charitable
um you know donations and contributions
i'm just not sure that they're all
equally
you know benefiting those of the public
sector or those of their internal
membership
it's just something to consider in way
so representative what is your
recommendation
um i'm not sure that formulated an
opinion but i do think that the
you know not each one of these 501c
subsections
in my opinion should be benefiting from
a public
charitable donation for instance
you know fraternal lodges who are
benefiting
themselves for
you know their own purposes to further
their organizations
i'm not sure that we should be allowing
them to benefit from public
funds to support themselves internally i
mean i'm not sure that that's the
intent of the original bill if it was
going directly to the community broadly
perhaps it's just something you need to
consider um
do you feel that's something that should
be
melded into the waiver requirement
well i think the waiver requirement is
actually a pretty strong
um it's a strong argument for trying to
find
um other charitable trusts and other
organizations that don't fit that
two-year period
under the secretary of state filing or i
think it's one year sorry
um it's it's important that a waiver
should be allowed i think that
especially if they're if those
organizations have already qualified for
a 501c3
tax exempt status um but i
i do have concerns about um for instance
you know
it is possible to be a 501c3
and have less than 20 of your revenue
or your distributions being
um allocated to lobbying efforts
for instance so that could be a
political
subsection of that not 501c3
those activities could be donated
towards a specific
issue area of a specific policy and
um although they don't meet the
threshold to be considered a lobbyist
those are you know some lobbying
activities
so should we be supporting
these subsections in those
limited but possibly material
activities and i just think it's you
know we need to be aware that that is
a possibility and then make our own
decisions of whether or not
you know new hampshire should be
supporting that through
legislation so um
i think the waiver is important because
it allows um
pretty distinctively to say you know in
this amendment that it would have
these funds would have to be these
organizations be operating
and primarily in the state of new
hampshire
and that the revenue raised by the
organization participating would be used
to benefit
the state so i think that's an important
caveat
i wouldn't want to lose that for any
waiver but
i mean i guess the question is if
they're applying this revenue towards a
lobbying effort
to the state of new hampshire issue area
that's
highly divisive is that something we
want to support
could you outline
a set of tests
that you feel would be
very beneficial to the state
and allow these
charities that
would fit the waiver if
they pass these tests i know i looked at
the book
and it is a book it's a huge book
it doesn't stop
if we put a bill in that went through
every 51z we have a separate journal
just for that so
what we do need is to have
something that covers specific cases and
you brought out some
good points that they had to the new
hampshire
organization benefit new hampshire
charitable things and that sort of thing
so
maybe you could put out some uh
guidelines
that could be good to consider for next
week
i will do my best to try to add
to that um discussion i'm not sure that
um you know that's that's a pretty large
task you're asking for well
just from just from my you know attorney
brain
that i occasionally use when i sit in my
representative's chair
is just it's very difficult to try to
prevent
you know any loophole around the system
and i
that is our job is to try to think
through these scenarios
something perfect we can we can probably
improve the
not only the amendment but the bill
itself i'm sure with a few ideas
fine if you could do that though really
i think make more people comfortable
about this
on representative major can i uh just
ask
representative heckin phillips another
question
about this from the beginning of what
she was talking about before we
give this one up okay uh
romney has had his hand up i know he's
going to a different thing i think
norma representative can go first before
me
thank you on it's about c4s
i know c4 is fairly well all the ones i
know
are politic for political lobbying
purposes and political
no for political election purposes
yeah i don't know how they got there
from the definition
that you you uh read us but
that's what they are i'm sure the nra
has
won the family plan uh planned
parenthood has one
uh the aclu has one yeah that was not
for election it's for lobbying but
so information that representative
phillips
can put together as part of the
requirements
and that would be more like a broad
brush if they meet these requirements
then we stand a better chance of getting
later but
i mean we could make this very
complicated
but let's make it a good bill
yeah now representative brown
thank you mr chair um let's let's first
recognize that the bill
forget about the amendment that i just
uh provided
has nothing to do with these 501c
the six of them all it does the reason
they're bolded is because they're
crossed out of
two other sections and put into two
other sections so
the the sponsor of the bill wasn't
adding additional 501cs or whatever
it was just a a replacement of the
language within the statute
so in my 11 years on ways of means
we've never tackled this question of are
these the appropriate
uh codes to be using
and and and charitable gaming's only
been around a decade and a half
so and probably bingo longer but
uh so i think it's a major task for us
to take on
at this point in time uh to to look at
all these codes
so i uh uh in fairness i i think
either we didn't retain the bill
if we really want to study these codes
to see where i would start with to say
okay which of the current charities
are falling to which of the i'm curious
about
that which ones are 501 uh c3s and which
ones are 50c10s
and we may flush something out there
that no no 503
10 actually uses this uh
uh or is is the current
user so this is a big question this is
beyond this bill
to me representative uh hack and
phillips
i think you're right on beam though uh
more from the perspective that we
haven't looked at this in years
uh so i think
my my opinion is that either we pass it
the way it is
and then file a bill to to study this or
study it as a committee
or just to retain it if we're willing to
all put the work in
in the late summer and in the fall to
really look at all these codes to see
what's in them
so that's that's just my opinion on that
i think we're taking on a big bite here
uh to really try to amend
all of these codes or add some or delete
some
uh within the framework of this bill
thank you
and i would recommend that
if we have there should be caucuses
of both parties before next tuesday
this is one thing to be considered as
far as
going into every one of these
the river to doing that but if you come
up with
it's possible and hopefully rips and
hack and phillips
come up with something that one of the
things that we're concerned with
not referring to a 501c but these are
the things we're concerned with
that the money doesn't go to a
lobbying and doesn't go to these other
things without
specifically saying a 501
and so we need to make the determination
do we want to pass the bill as it is do
we want to retain it
do we want to amend it with
some guidelines
and so uh but we need to we need to make
up our mind to do something with it
uh representative ames
followed by representing newly actually
i just want to say that i i i agree with
the
direction we seem to be going um
[Music]
i i want to note that there is uh we're
very close
to seeing the enactment of uh either
house bill 565 which
i sponsored or it's equivalent that's
come over to us from the senate as part
of an omnibus bill
um and that bill will be
uh establishing establishing a committee
to study charitable gaming
and certainly this this uh
sort of this uh core concern about what
is a
a charitable organization should be part
of that study
and we could make sure that it is uh i
do think it's a complicated endeavor
when we get beyond the few sort of
general words that can be said i i think
that on this bill
we should take a hard look to see if
there's a there's a
fix that addresses this waiver question
and that doesn't get
tangled up with the complexities too
much
maybe there is maybe there isn't but
let's take a hard look at that
and maybe we can act on the bill um but
um i think there is a larger issue here
that's really important
and uh and that there's another vehicle
available to us other than retaining and
studying
which has its d has its problems um
so that's my contribution mr chair if i
could just chime in real quick
i'm cutting i know i actually had the
same thought as representative
ames did about this romney
i had a question for representatives
okay
ruxin ames maybe you could work with
representative hackens
and see if there's some simple rules
that we could implement
rather than getting into the
complexities of
501 c 3 4 5 19
et cetera yeah we'll talk okay
thank you uh go ahead representative
sarge no i'm sorry about that mr chair i
i was just saying that i
actually had the same thought about
maybe wrapping this into the
study committee with the senate so
uh that may have some merits that's all
thank you
right before i go to the next one
representative
ames mentioned house bill 565
and representative romney had
jen duo side by side
with one part of senate bill 100
to see what was the difference between
the two of them has that been
distributed to
committee members you know yes yes it
should have been yes
good we'll give an update
thank you uh mr chair um representative
hack and phillips spoke about um
501 c8s and c10s those are two of which
i
i know and and i work with 501ch 501c8s
just
to give you some idea would be things
like the knights of columbus the knights
of pitheos
the knights of uh there's a couple other
nights that aren't affiliated with
anything
yeah odd fellows uh
catholic uh foresters and foresters
insurance companies
i believe are all 501c8 whereas a 501c10
is not basically uh carved out for the
uh
masons alone as far as money is go going
from um
charitable uh gaming to uh
the operation of the entity i think
that's a good idea and i would be happy
to work with representative ames and
representative hacken phillips on that
good
rep thank you on representative abrami
said
something about on this was just
codifying this language is just
codifying
what i wasn't sure what what is already
being done
without legislation or
is maybe found in the bingo code
where i thought that this was
expanding on that
we were now just with c3s but
but on can we get clarification
from lottery as to whether this language
exists somewhere
else or whether it's in your rules or or
whatever
thank you um can i can i respond to that
mr chair
go ahead and representative go to page
two of the bill
if you have that in front of you i need
mine's uh
lines four
well basically uh four that see it's
crossed out
all the codes there and if you go down
to line 18
the same thing all they did was they
moved they
basically did some housekeeping on the
statute
and put those back in because there's
two spots where they got added back in
on on page one of the bill
on line 15 and page
two uh line
nine and line eight and nine
so thank you i just noticed that
right so it isn't like they these were
new these are the
these are the codes we've been using
since the beginning of time
is my point and that's why i said do we
really want to take this on
at this moment uh we didn't it isn't
like the bill added other
other uh uh 501c codes to deal with or
or or to agree that takes them away
uh if we want to make that into that
then that's going to take some time
is my only concern and if we had another
month maybe we
we could we could do that but you could
take a crack at it
and see how we do but uh and again like
i said earlier
i agree with representative ames that
be the appropriate place for it would be
within that study study committee
thank you all right
any further questions or comments on
senate bill
and then hopefully with uh
representative neroli representative
ames and representative films
working together we may have a solution
the next bill is hospit i mean senate
bill
139-fn relative to bingo dates
let's see if this is going to be a
complicated involved
uh anybody have any
comments questions on
senate bill 139
well representative
of romney followed by representative
elmi
the the real question is um
i think senator senator avar did this
for one
one location in his district
and i've had some conversations with
some others since the bill was heard
and that not all the not all the bingo
halls
are well again they didn't testify but
uh but it's my understanding that not
all the bingo halls agree with this
uh there could be a compromise
where we not you know because
one question i had asked was will this
force some charities
out of uh because they basically
um you know if we we
give more more dates to some charities
that would mean that other charities
would would have less
dates assuming that all the dates were
taken now we heard testimony that
in this one facility that not all the
dates were being taken
but i i've i've heard that from
what's his name uh michael mclaughlin
who we hear from a lot on our committee
that he knows of at least four that have
waiting lists
for for this so uh so
it seems like this bill is is trying to
solve a problem for one
one establishment and potentially could
be creating
a problem for other establishments that
are bingo halls
so that that's i love how to speak but
uh
that's my only concern right now and and
i i have to think about
maybe amending this but i don't have a
specific
thing that would would allow for
possibly uh
three or four extra days uh a period
uh if if someone wants but i i
i don't know um i just concerned that
there might be
uh we may doing hard to some other
charities here
thank you thank you uh representative
army
thank you mr chairman on
having listened to both sides of this
i really do not understand why we are
still
trying to regulate the game dates for
bingo
bingo as far as i can tell
we haven't had an update on bingo for
quite a long time now
on how i don't know how many bingo halls
are left that are just doing bingo on
they how many
um charities are interested in working
with them is versus
the much more profitable on
charitable gaming ones and um
if we just as it is it doesn't read
you have to give 16 game dates to one
charity it only
reads you have to give you can give up
to
that many uh
which but if we just
i don't know if we just excised all of
the reference
to how many games you can give to
whoever
whether the halls could then just figure
out how many charities they wanted to
divvy it up among
okay is there any organization of bingo
halls that
we could talk to uh john do you have a
response to that
i'm not sure if mr newman also
represents some bingo halls or some
um um overlap between
uh bingo and uh games of chance
operators
um i think with any more specific
questions regarding bingo i would defer
to valerie king who's also on the zoom
um if you have specific questions about
the current state of bingo
could you bring let valerie and please
thank you
be on our way valerie were you able to
listen to the discussion on that
hi i just got on i think you're talking
to me this is valerie king with new
hampshire lottery
yes and what was the question
the question had to do is uh
a couple parts is how many bengal halls
are there
left and
there is
oh answer that one first i
there are approximately 15 licensed
commercial bingo halls
in new hampshire still some of them
operate
larger venues than others but there are
15 total that are licensed
okay
yes thank you on it
it was what would it do to the current
situation
if we just removed all requirements
as to how many game dates each charity
could get
well i i don't i don't really have an
answer for that um
right now it's 10 we could open it up to
more
i don't know that there would be a an
effect or not i
as you as you mentioned representative
amy this
bill wouldn't prevent the halls from
having
keeping it to 10 game dates for
charities or even less
it would just allow that they could go
up to 16.
as far as the agency is concerned that
wouldn't be a heavy lift for us we just
have to
um increase the number of game dates
allowed
um it would require them to pay for more
per month
which could be a financial cost up front
it's only 25 dollars per game date but
if they were to do
every day of the month that could be
expensive but other than that i
do not i'm not aware of any issues
okay any further questions uh for
valerie
uh representative brownlee yeah uh
thanks mr chair thanks uh miss king
so uh how many of the charitable gaming
locations also offer bingo i
i i think it's five or six in my head
but uh do you have that up
and is that is that above and beyond the
15 that you mentioned
no that they're included in the 15
um and of those we have lakes region
which does both games a chance and bingo
lucky seven
uh concord casino
uh dover bowl ocean gaming
lebanon poker room the manchester poker
room
and i believe that's it so six of them
six of the 15
are also games of chance halls okay so
they have both licenses
yes okay thank you
for the questions of valerie
saying none
any other questions relative to senate
bill 139
uh mr chair mr chair is if uh
mike mclaughlin is on the on the call on
the zoom uh
can we bring him in just to offer his
comments that he shared would you bring
him in
i do not see him okay
then that's the answer
no yeah i don't see them either
okay thank you
mr chair there is an attendee with their
hand up
it's the phone number ending in zero
eight nine
just allowed them to talk
okay 0 8 9 would you identify yourself
is that a star sexual star knight
i believe it's star six to unmute good
morning can you hear me now as they say
yes hello
hi this is mike from a bob eastwood
representing community maintenance
international
uh 139. uh
i had some discussion with
representative browning relatively the
impact of the 16 states
and to ohio which has a waiting list
the possibility existed would actually
eliminate charities
as opposed to adding to them so i had to
ask uh
the thoughts together that maybe uh an
option of
three additional dates a month would be
work workable
and that the uh some of the bengals
spartans testified
relative to the fact that they run into
some odd months and they'd like to have
that extra day
we don't see that a 60 increase in the
dates
is something that actually is uh going
to be benefits uh
particularly if there's a waiting list a
high um
performing charity may be able to force
others out so that was the unintended
consequence i had mentioned at the
hearing
several weeks ago and while we recognize
there are some charities
and there are some halls where there are
available dates i think a little more
control
over the dates is a good good thought
any further questions to ask mike
can i ask representative romney
mr mclaughlin um so
what do you think of su representative
almi's suggestion that we just do away
with
well i i think it's an interesting
suggestion but i think that the
control factor if i had a super charity
if i could run
30 days a month why would i want more
than one that carryover coverall would
zoom
every night uh i i think the limitation
of dates actually is the protection to
the charities
okay thank you
representative
sorry on i i guess he answered why he
thinks that
doesn't trust the halls to do right by
their charities
thank you
i trust the house to do right by their
owners
any further questions
[Music]
all right all right thank you mr
chairman
well thank you any further
issues to discuss on senate bill 139
saying then i'm going to close the
work session on senate bill 139
the next bills
is senate bill 103-fn
i don't know why i got one of 103.
101-fn
increase in the minimum gross business
income required
for filing a business profits tax return
then we have an amendment offered by
representative early and represent almi
and before we get into that amendment
it was a question that we asked
of the dra the ira was asked
what would the cost be
rather than implementing 75
000 as as the trigger
but 85 and 100 000. and i believe
we've all received a copy of this
before we get into the right
representation to go over
the amendment and and represent nearly
i'm going to have to drop off because
i've got to go see
a surgeon and representative abrami
will take over
hey thank you mr chair sorry about that
no problem thank you good luck norm
thank you good luck right
so uh representative almi uh well first
off is department of revenue
on the call on his own
um yes i see carolyn lear
devon rodrick has his hand up so i'll
promote him
uh yeah you can promote both of them but
uh
uh uh uh commission assistant
commissioner uh lear is the one i wanna
talk to
oh and i'll promote melissa rollins as
well
uh so uh can you just quickly
explain what you did on the uh on what
you mailed out to all of us
uh i don't know carolyn if if you feel
someone else's one of your team get that
better just let me know
hi representative sorry this is carolyn
it took a minute for my
screen to refresh when i got promoted
i'm gonna let
devin give you an explanation of what
he's done
since he performed the actual analysis
hello representatives this is devin
roderick financial analyst department of
revenue
we took a look at the two additional um
proposed thresholds amounts that we sent
to you
and we um we we applied the same
analysis
for the original senate bill 101 which
increased the
gross business income threshold from
fifty thousand
to seventy five thousand and we applied
that to tax year twenty eighteen
information
and we took a look at federal tax
information in order to come up with
the results that you see there in the
chart um the number of taxpayers
who filed tax year 2018 returns as you
can see in each
each row of that chart are the same
that's using the same data
so the original analysis for sb101
moving that threshold to 75000 had an
estimated impact
of 1.5 million and affected
essentially 660 taxpayers during that
tax year
if you increase it to 85 000
it would essentially impact 896
taxpayers who had liability during that
tax year
and the impact would be 2.1 million
and with a hundred thousand the impact
would be 2.9
million impacting 1221 taxpayers who had
liability
so overall um in each instance you can
see that rona said had zero
bpt liability those were taxpayers that
after everything said and done didn't
actually owe any money to the department
that year
so we want to make sure we broke out who
was actually and the number of
taxpayers that were actually impacted
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
that you have
okay thank you devon uh does anyone have
any questions specifically for devon
on mine fits within that i think i
wanted to ask them
if on i
i looked at the inflation since
1993 on
to march to march of this year
on it comes out to
on the 50 000 changes to 92.2
000. um and
that is for for my
interpretation of two data sets for
northeast urban
on for the national one it changes to
91.7
thousand on
if on in our
in the amendment that representative
ulri fashioned
on there is uh
he's put the hundred thousand but it
we seem to be some at just about halfway
between 85 and 100
000 in terms of inflation since that
time
and i was wondering if on devin had
any thoughts about the way i calculated
the northeast urban or
well we could just say it was 92 000 if
we were going to do inflation
i don't have any questions about that
because i haven't i haven't actually
looked
at myself the time frame that you
mentioned um
i would mention that the bet thresholds
are adjusted by annually
using i believe the data you just
mentioned in northeast urban
um and that's been in place since 2015 i
believe
so um i'd have to take a look at you
know i trust the information you're
saying represent elmi but i don't really
have any questions about that at this
time
thank you i think it was passed in 2012
but
15 may have been the first time you did
that
okay thank you devon um representative
rory
if you could walk us through the
amendment you have your hand up as well
so
um but do you have a question of of uh
devin or
do you also no no not at all i was just
uh looking at the uh
um the figures here and the
what's not accounted for in this is what
susan or
representative almi had just stated
regarding the rate of inflation
and there's also uh a bit of a concern
about the amount of money that is now
floating around being spent everywhere
that
the dollar amount of uh three million
dollars
at a hundred thousand is not going to be
worth
three million dollars uh because of the
uh
uh devaluation of the value of the
dollar by
six trillion dollars being pumped into
the economy
from different places uh let me see
you've all got a copy of the uh
uh amendment in front of you correct
uh they were sent out to everybody yeah
so let's just take a look at that hang
on a second before i pull it up
there it goes
all it does is change the threshold to
100 000
and then uses existing language and
other law to put an inflation bait
rate in now if we want to
leave it at 75 or increase it to 85
um that's immaterial uh
the the key factor on this is adding and
uh
i think uh representing lonely will
agree would be adding a two-year review
to take a look at what the inflation
value
uh is based upon the northeast region
consumers northeast region digest
index excuse me so that you
have that based in law and we don't have
to review this
every few years and it gives our
small businesses which you know 100 one
plumber may
with an individual shop earning a
hundred thousand dollars
if he has to pay taxes on a hundred
thousand dollars he's not
particularly earning a hundred thousand
dollars
uh and you know that's a
a reasonable rate of return for one
particular license now if it's a shop
like uh the guy that sells all the hats
there on radio that you hear all the
time
um shop like that he's got
um a lot more uh revenue coming in
and he's not a one-man shop the idea of
this
is to make sure that the one-man shop
the smaller businesses
have a break from having to file
unnecessary paperwork
that's it any questions uh yeah i do
and then uh and then represent southward
uh so
i just want to make sure this is
identical to the bet
language that's what i asked them to put
in and
uh they you know i i trust uh
aols to um you know or whatever it is on
legislative services to do their um
and the other other concern is that it's
in sync with that the
[Music]
uh it's on the same year that the the
index is applied every two years and
that those those two dates are in sync
in terms of i'll i'll check without um
like thank you on that
uh representative romney we'll um
we'll check and make sure but i told
them to do that when they put it in here
so it may be a
small change on that thank you
representative southworth ah thank you
mine is a comment
although i never like to lose revenue
this does seem like a fair amendment
and i do think within the near future
we'll be at 100 000 being fair
anyway so i'm you know especially with
some of susan's numbers and things
i think we're going to be there
eventually and i do think it is
something that is fair
thank you representative amy
thank you um i i've got two things now
um the first one is is if we started a
hundred thousand
now on and inflation does
increase uh quite a bit then that will
be
exploding i'm uh faster than
than otherwise i'd rather go with the 92
i know it's a strange number
but on also i think we can get uh
dra devin or someone to to tell us
if it's the exact same language i'm
pretty sure
it is um i put that
in the bill that was passing
in 2012
basically because it is extremely
painful when you have to
increase after 10 years or 20 years
on on the floor and
you lose a lot more revenue all of a
sudden and you haven't been used to
doing that
so in in addition it is much better for
the businesses
because it's painful for them to get
inflated
into to a category
uh year by year waiting for us to change
things
so um my other my only other
comment was that on
there is a request in the
quick guide to change the
applicability date
and i think that ought to be in the
amendment on
change to periods for taxable periods
ending on
or after december 31 2022
to ensure that the proposed change
impacts
uh all taxpayers fairly
for the 22 tax year
so i think that we ought to include that
in the amendment
huh all right so i i think that's a good
idea then if
uh does anybody from the dra just want
to comment on that
suggestion yes representative we'd be
happy to review the amendment
and um our group will take a look at it
and get back to you with any
comments or questions on the wording of
it and i'll jump in devin
um because i think what you're asking is
for us to comment on that uh requested
change
is that right yes um so this really the
the change that we requested would
really impact
a taxpayer that has a short period
return
meaning a tax year that ends
before a full 12 months because of
when we're able to create our forms
if the taxpayer had a short return our
forms wouldn't properly reflect the
changes
changed threshold um with the current
due date and so having um i'm sorry
applicability date so
changing the applicability date would
ensure that you know every possible
permutation of
tax year would be properly
reflected on the return a taxpayer would
use
uh that makes sense to me uh does
anybody have any
problem with ms lear's uh
suggestion and if not uh represent
almi it sounds like you should amend
your amendment to
include that right and uh representative
representative i'm not sure who's in
charge of this amendment
i'm sorry uh it doesn't make any
difference
but susan on because she brought it up
and
if she wants to take credit that's fine
i see material
uh i have a couple questions real quick
uh
is everyone comfortable with a hot one
uh 100
uh no representative schamberg i think
susan has suggested it's a good starting
spot
it gives us room to get to 100 000 in
three years
i i know real quick
uh i i know the chair wasn't comfortable
with going the full hundred
uh in my conversation with him so
perhaps the 92 would help be helpful
you may want to have uh jordan you may
want to have two amendments one with the
92 and one with the
100 and then we can just
what the votes are yeah and what's the
applicable date on that
again would be this uh
carolyn
representative
yeah i don't have my quick guide here
i'm looking for it i
i can't find it would you like me to
email it to you representative would
that be easier
yes please thank you you're welcome no i
got it
okay all right uh let's see
uh representative um geneviean
and then followed by uh representative
um
is that southworth or is that tom
amber huh bamberg
chamber okay so i'll take down my hand
oh okay so representative uh janae again
thank you mr chair uh this is just a
general question for dra
um i just want to compare it let's let's
say
the the uh deduction was a hundred
thousand uh or the the
threshold was a hundred thousand um
therefore a business who grosses uh
less than a hundred thousand doesn't
file um a return
if a business makes a hundred thousand
or grosses a hundred thousand
and ten dollars and let's say they they
net
thirty thousand but the business that
grossed a hundred thousand that didn't
have to file also net thirty thousand
does that mean the business
that grossed a hundred thousand doesn't
pay any taxes but the business
grows to hundred thousand and ten pays
taxes
that's correct um it's really the
difference between a filing
threshold versus an exemption so for
example under the interest and dividends
tax the first
2400 is wholly exempt
whether you make 2401
in interest or a million in interest
the first 2400 is exempt but with a
threshold
once you trip that threshold
everything is taxable back to dollar one
so it almost it almost gives a business
i'm sorry follow-up
um it almost gives a business an
incentive to
i mean if they're close to try to keep
it below that because it's it almost
creates a
unfair scenario where and this is that's
why this is just a general question in
general i'm just trying to think if you
grossed 101
you know 101 000 you could be paying
you know 7.7 percent of let's say a 30
net but the one that grows you know less
than a hundred thousand
didn't pay anything but i guess that's
i mean that that's a maybe a discussion
for a future day
thank you for that it's good insight um
then that that would be a major
change in philosophy i guess that would
be
take us a while to work through i think
so right
thank you representative thank you
on this is a problem with thresholds
that
on i've been having to deal with since
1999 when we were working on education
funding
um it's on the only alternative to that
is a cascading one where you have
one uh one rule for the people
that are between 80 and 85 and another
for 85 to 90 and so on
all the way up and uh that it's
more complicated than anyone wants to
deal with
but it it does occur throughout
legislation in
odd ways sometimes
okay okay any other questions
okay so uh to the dra
uh devin you're going to do the
calculation at the 92
000 level uh get that to
to us uh hopefully sometime this week
uh in jordan you're going to um
i would i would just create a uh a
second amendment
keep your first amendment live at the
hundred thousand
and then to create another one with the
92 000 is that okay
with you well actually we're going to
have to modify them both to put the um
the date in there the other question is
could i ask dra if they could uh do an
analysis
on the 92 and 95 just for giggles
that's totally fine yes representative
thank you
all right so any other questions
okay with that we're going to move on
then to the next
build which is
senate bill 103.
um
hey uh is there any discussion on this
um the chair doesn't have any comments
on this one
um
[Music]
yeah i had a comment um okay question
okay uh
all right representative and rep senator
spellsbury next after that
yeah sorry to break in uh it's just that
uh my
my notes indicate that uh uh we were
expecting
uh an amendment uh
by dra there's some issue
technical issue with this i i just have
that note
i'm trying to look at my notes here i
don't see that but uh carolyn
can you chime in please no i don't
believe that there were any
um technical issues with this one
um i think what we had talked about with
you
was just our understanding of where this
legislation is coming from
and that it relates more to um or is
more impactful in states with personal
income taxes
where businesses actually have to
register
with the department of revenue and
orchestrate withholding
for employees before they send them to
the state
and i think here in new hampshire where
there's no income tax and therefore no
withholding requirements
there's no real barrier to entry from
our perspective
it's really whether or not the um
the subsequent activity in new hampshire
results in a tax obligation or not
yeah i think i think it was that review
and input that we were looking for so
that's fine
okay thank you um representative
spellsbury
thank you mr chairman um yeah my note
also
indicated apparently dira has an
amendment but
i didn't know what it was my question is
the phrase upon request by which comes
up
two thirds of the way down page two
under notification
and in the hearing i had asked the
question and i
i don't think i really understood
any clear answer how is the secretary of
state supposed to discern
the presence of this emergency force
and take initiative to put out a request
but before we get to the representative
what line on page two are you on
sure unfortunately i put off uh
i found it thank you thank you
yeah under this is under notification
and so
it reads any out-of-state business that
is present
in the state or conducts operations in
the state to perform disaster related or
emergency related work during a disaster
response period
shall provide upon request by the
secretary of state
written statement so it just
uh it would seem to me that the shoe has
to be on the other foot that the
company who's sending in a force has to
let secretary of state know they're
there
seems very simple but i just have a
feeling this is one
that would be very difficult in practice
can i ask the dra if they have any any
input on this
this language
uh representative this is carolyn again
i
don't have any insight on that language
i think that part in particular relates
more to the business licensing
aspect than the tax exemption
okay thank you uh representative
almighty
thank you i think that this we've been
given this bill as something that if we
change it it's going to mess up
everybody in the national agreement
and it makes it rather difficult for
things like this where our secretary of
state's
corporations office doesn't really do
much
in the way of noticing or regulating
businesses
they just volunteer to be registered
um and i don't know if they're getting
better about that there have been some
reforms since i last
talked to that division which was very
hard to talk to
um but uh the secretary of state is the
one that keeps the
the uh forums saying that yes i'm a
corporation
right and in that light wouldn't it be
more sensible for the secretary of state
to passively receive a notice of
presence
put it in a file until such time as it
might be needed
but we're told if we add anything to
this bill or delete anything that we're
going
to make trouble for the entire national
decision okay i don't feel strongly but
it strikes me as a wrinkle in practice
that's a good find actually but um i can
reach out to the secretary of state
i'm sure he's not even aware of this
reach out to the head of the corporate
division right
i don't know who that is nowadays but i
can find out i don't either but i
understand that
it's an improvement i like the idea of
soliciting secretary of state's opinion
before we pass this
yeah i'll do that i know him quite well
so i'll reach out to him and then i'll
have a quick conversation with him and
then have him point me to his
corporate division person all right so
uh any other comments on this bill yeah
i'd like to just comment
on that last discussion
i think the uh i i don't know but i
i i think that the goal of this
legislation is to enable
emergency responses to uh go forward
without
being encumbered by unnecessary
uh red tape and um
that probably and i'm just
i'd like to hear actually from the uh
components of this bill more than from
the secretary of state
they were trying to develop
a envelope within which
business could operate without having
in the first instance to clear a hurdle
with the secretary of state
um and perhaps this language about
notification
which is triggered only by a request by
the secretary of state
is to enable people to go
to the secretary of state and say hey
this business is in our state uh and
um and this needs to
um go through a review process
because of this or that in other words
it's it's
uh it's it's sort of enabling a uh
complaint a concern to be brought to the
attention of
the secretary of state and then to have
a procedure that's in place for the
secretary of state to follow
that's that's just a i suppose a guess
on my part trying to make sense of this
because obviously the secretary of state
in the ordinary course wouldn't know
about these businesses
so i'd like to hear from the sponsors
about this sponsor get the explanation
the sponsor is senator bradley i can
reach out to senator bradley
and see if he can spare some time next
week or
even tomorrow
maybe hard to get a hold of him right
away but i'll try this afternoon
track him down and see if he's uh
willing to
shed some light on this okay
yeah if i could we have to remember
that this is a model bill that has not
been changed
it is meant for the entire country
and the idea
is that you wouldn't have to look up
each state's regulations before
you went racing in to help and
on that other states i am quite sure
on that their secretaries of state
do more than our corporate division does
what the corporate division does
uh well maybe they're doing a bit more
now but
but what they're supposed they're
charged with doing is
to accept on requests for
on certification of your business and
your title
at the title of your business some of
you may have noticed
that about trapping
that just got resolved through a lawsuit
where
a guy who was a trapper took over
the corporate names of of
on two organizations set up by a woman
who was running an anti-trapping
group and hadn't thought to register her
names
and uh i've tried to look at that a
number of times trying to figure out how
many businesses we've got that are
really businesses active
in this state they don't or at least
a couple of years ago they still had no
idea
they'll register something and then they
won't do anything with it
so so it's really a question of asking
the corporate division
what it's doing now but we've got to
remember that
our secretary of state's office is
different than all the others
in the country that's a good point so
i'll reach out to both um
and we'll go from there any other
comments questions okay
so hopefully we'll get some information
and and perhaps some
additional testimony next week
on this all right
the next one is senate bill
which is the the senate version of the
charitable gaming bill
uh the senate as you're all aware i
think that
it did pass 620 house spell 626
it passed on consent last week uh with
no changes
so that's that's already in the works um
in the conversation with with senator um
guida he's and and
senator french who's the prime sponsor
of this
of of uh of 112
uh that uh he's willing to
make 626 the primary bill
and has no problem if we were to retain
this bill
uh or whatever we decide to do with it
but uh but that's that's already worked
out with the senate
so there they're in agreement that 626
moves forward
and if we want to we want to kill off
112 they're okay with that so
uh so i don't know i think the debate
we've had to debate on this it's just
their bills are identical
with one or two little grammatical
issues that
uh there that are there that are minor
minor
uh so um does anybody have any
comments or other input they want on on
on this bill
seeing none okay we'll move forward
and the last bill
is senate bill three
um
so here's what's going to happen
tomorrow morning
uh and i think we started
10 tomorrow um we were able to
secure two two two uh
one of the one of the one of them i
forget their names now but
uh one of them is the chair of the
tax accountants group
and and one other very active tax
accountant
that uh will give us a sense of
what they think their members
or their their their advice that their
members had given
to to the various
tax tax attorneys in terms of and they
did a
informal poll over the weekend that
they're going to share with us
they said they didn't have time to do
anything formal uh to give us a sense of
how much of that
uh 75 million or uh
that was collected in business taxes was
really
due to their advice that they
file under current statute and not uh
under sb three
uh changes so so that's
that's one big thing that we you know
that we've been asking for and uh
and the dra is
also going to still owes us some
information
on if we do pass this
what is the implication from
tax wise for next fiscal year
and the year after that as well as
the year that um people just filed for
which was uh uh 20.
so um so that's why we stand in that and
then we also have an amendment
uh that's coming and i i know
representative spillsbury
um shared with us not the actual
amendment but what the
what what the amendment will actually
say
and if you wanted to i think the
amendment came in
representative abrami the uh formal
amendment came from oelis this morning
at 8 45. so
i was only able to forward a short time
before our session this morning
all right um but it looks
pretty much exactly like your language i
think
it's identical did not change that's
right right thank you
at 9 15 this morning so do we want to
spend a few minutes now just
talking through that amendment um
representative spillsbury
sure um i suppose i could go on at great
length but we've all been hearing the
same thing so i won't recap everything
we've heard
uh essentially congress acted in two
stages
when they enacted the cares act in march
they did provide to have forgiven debt
excluded
from taxable income because the normal
rule under the internal revenue code
is whenever debt is forgiven it's
taxable
it wasn't until their december
um second stage law that they
also made it clear
that expenses can be deducted so that as
it stands is the federal situation
by the accounting we've heard 22 states
conform automatically
another group of states has taken action
to conform and that leaves 11 states
that apparently are poised to
leave forgiven ppp debt is taxable in
new hampshire of course is one of those
because we don't automatically conform
because we refer two years back so
2018 version of the code
applies so i just want to point out that
whether to act to conform regarding the
non-taxation of forgiven ppp
is one issue and it is distinct
from the question whether to also
conform to the december legislation
allowing further deduction uh that lives
outside the internal revenue code
and in the same way that they were dealt
with separately at two different times
by
congress i don't want us to view them
as though they're necessarily entwined
we can have
one or the other or neither or both
um so we have 25 000 businesses in new
hampshire who have received ppp
loans and of course
we have nsv3 a proposal
both to exclude those from
taxable income and also in
paragraph two to allow the expenses to
be further deducted so the purpose of
the amendment
is to reverse paragraph
two so that instead of saying no
deduction shall be denied
it says no deduction shall be allowed
but with the dras
help we've also included no tax
attributes will be adjusted
and no basis shall be adjusted for an
expense
that is otherwise deductible if the
payment
at the expense results in forgiveness uh
and the income associated with
forgiveness is excluded from gross
income
pursuant to paragraph one which is to
say specifically
in the context of the ppp and the
following
law so so that's the proposal the
proposal of this amendment
is to take those two issues
treat them separately and reach a
different conclusion
so sb3 would then exclude
forgiven debt from taxable income
but it would not then allow the
deductions which qualified
that ppp fund for uh
forgiveness to be used against
other income so so can i assess a
question right there
so so let's say there's salaries
or normally a business expense that
would come off
the revenue as we work our way down to
what the net profit is correct
that's correct what we're saying is that
uh with your amendment
we would not allow those
anything that was paid for by ppp
cannot be deducted is that correct
whatever the expense is
whether it's or you know that's exactly
correct so just just to clarify uh
representative romney
um the
the cares act established two different
uh criteria one is that you had to use
the funds for qualified expenses
and you had to use at least 60 percent
of it
for payroll i suspect that in many cases
100 of it was used for payroll but
that's not material
you would get your loan forgiven
if you spend it for qualified expenses
at least 60
of which were payroll so we know
inherently that any expenses that
qualify the ppp for forgiveness
um are the same kinds of expenses that
could be deducted
in in our ppt tax
right so um then my next question i know
this is from hands
um so what does this do
to the numbers is this something that
you've asked the dra to take a look at
as well i i've asked but i was advised
that
uh until it was determined what
direction the committee wanted to take
they were going to hold off
uh i think it's fair to say
that the bulk of the 91 million dollars
that was estimated as a reduction of
revenue to the state
um would be reversed
there are some complications i i i'm not
entirely sure that in all cases 100
of the ppp uh loans have been offset by
deductible expenses
and we also have the question of how the
bet
factors into things so i i do
i am anxious to see dras assessment but
i think it's fair to assume most of the
91 million would be
um retained okay
we've got three hands on the verbs of
almighty then representative ames and
uh represent representative gennady and
president romney thank you on
this this amendment
would hit the businesses that are
struggling and not all of the one
the trouble is that not all of the
businesses
that got ppp were struggling i
bet not half of them were
but struggling badly but the ones that
were that got the ppp loans
to give um keep their employees
and give gave them that make work
and got very little profit during that
period that they were closed down
and maybe after for a while as they were
coming back
they have lost months or a year
of of profits
if we do this on and
well they have lost a month months or a
year of profits
and on are trying to bring their
business back
up to normal now and
would have to pay tax on on
on last year on what profit they did get
so it's a question in there about
how many of the businesses had enough
profit that they would be showing
up for bpt
in the first place on but
for whom the profit
that they did did have enough profit to
be
taxed but that profit was not their
normal profit
and was not what they were using
normally
for their own maintenance or to grow the
business
i don't see any uh impact of the be
on the bpt that they have to pay
from whether we do the bill as it is or
the amendment
uh i think that's that's just there as a
base
and so anybody who is only paying bet
isn't going to be affected by any of
this anyway
so several comments that's absolutely
correct sp3
exclusively addresses business profits
tax it's silent on business enterprise
tax
and likewise the amendment um follows
that
that same economy but
basically the approach of sbe3 unamended
can only benefit
a business that earned a profit
because we only tax profit we're not
taxing revenue there are states that
have gross receipts taxes we're not one
of them um
and so a business that uh
earned no profit isn't vulnerable to
being taxed or unforgiven ppp loans
a business that struggled without
generating profit wouldn't be exposed
one that closed permanently wouldn't be
exposed the greatest hardship cases
don't benefit from this bill at all
uh that's the irony of it and and i
could go on and on
the problem is the intended
beneficiaries primarily
in the cares act were the employees
the purpose was to try to enable
businesses to keep people
employed and give them the money to do
it
and of course there is a a
direct benefit to the employer as well
uh
to retaining those employees and keeping
the doors open and you know
i don't think anybody even at the time
the cares act was enacted
he anticipated the pandemic would endure
as long as it has so
everybody was sort of viewing it as a
short-term opportunity to live to fight
another day
but when you when you consider who the
intended beneficiaries are and then you
ask yourself
if sb3 passed unamended um
who would actually get the benefit
the more profitable business was the
more they would benefit from sb3
the more damage the business was by the
pandemic controls the less they'd
benefit
non-new hampshire businesses would
benefit just as much as new hampshire
donald businesses
large businesses would benefit more than
small businesses
and this could include multinationals
and foreign companies that often receive
ppp
through smaller us-based subsidiaries or
related entities
so and incidentally if we were
at the point where we were implementing
a single sales factor all of
that would just be amplified greatly
because we'd be relying more heavily on
non-new hampshire companies sales within
the state
so i i just think that
the more we consider this
the bill is a very blunt instrument i
i think i think that uh
the complaints on
on their surface are appealing if
somebody were actually
exposed to being taxed um
incrementally more than they you know
than the profits
that they would have earned otherwise i
can see how businesses would complain
that it's a harm
but i think much of this i used the term
illusion in in one of my questions in
the hearing i think
that the the fear and the concern
is largely imagined because
if if you've completely offset all of
your ppp funds
with qualified expenses there is no
incremental tax exposure
so i think there are probably other ways
if if we believe
politically that there are small
businesses and independent businesses
that continue to struggle there are
other ways to assist them more
effectively than this
and this probably won't help them
okay could i just ask would you
regard on applying
the the newer federal requirement that
they have lost 25
of their revenue during the pandemic
on as an alternative to this amendment
let's see i'm trying to think through
how that squares with what this bill
um is trying to do and what the
amendment is trying to do
um if they lost 25 of their business
are they a profitable business
sufficiently profitable
to exceed the threshold and be taxed
under the bpt
but they'd be they'd have lost it for
last year and be recovering now
okay i'm i'm not sure how this puts more
money in their hands but i may be
not seen this way uh
we're going to be discussing this again
tomorrow uh so
maybe you can think about that uh
representative spillsberry
and maybe sure you have a chance to
react to that okay
glad to thank you representative
so representative ames
yeah i i i think the um exchange that
just occurred
really addresses my concerns i i uh
i think the multi-year situation that
the
expenses occurred in the first year and
then
in the second year the loans forgiven
are
the situations that sort of pose
the trickiest uh um
situation to announce to to understand
and
to assess but uh in one year
a uh business let's say a pretty
big restaurant um
survives by by having that loan that
pays for the salaries of the staff that
uh that enable the restaurant to
continue
operating and they do receive revenue
um about equal to
this the cost of keeping the business
open
and so they come out of that year and
they file their return
let's say they they even get some some
profit so they have to file a return
they're above the threshold or maybe
they don't file a return
and and then in the second year in the
next year the loan's forgiven
and under this amendment now the those
expenses
they took in the previous year as i
understand it maybe i'm misunderstanding
it
would now no longer be deductible
so they'd have to file an amended return
and have a tax liability for that
previous year
or am i misunderstanding um
and now they go forward and the loan is
not
in the in the new tax year the loan is
is not revenue so that's good
um and there are no expenses related to
the loan
um so they go forward
and but they've got to they've now
they've got a tax liability
that relates to that first year that may
may be a hardship
i think you're raised in an interesting
question uh representative
ames and i want to think about it
further and i think we need to hear the
dras
assessment of that but just to be clear
uh
the ppp initially is alone so there's no
income
right and and and i think you you uh
you may be right that the forgiveness
might occur in a different
tax year
so now the income is
created but under sb3
as with the cares act gets excluded from
taxation so your question is the timing
of the
expenses that were deducted and
specifically we're speaking of those
expenses that were identified in the
process of
qualifying the ppp loan for forgiveness
did they occur in the same tax year as
the forgiveness i haven't thought about
that previously it's a great question
need some thought okay thank you
carolyn can you think about that a few
minutes i'm going to go to
representative danigan and if you can
just weigh in on that
last interchange uh but representative
genegan first
thank you mr chair i guess my question's
more to make sure i understand
the amendment fully because i want to
and i want to use an example to make
sure that i understand it
and that is if you have let's say your
ppp
loan is forgiven and that pp
loan represents one half of your
of your gross income now so it's it's
now on half but were you saying the
amendment
that the um that the the um
there's there can't be any adjusted
basis for expenses
does that mean none of the expenses i
mean i would expect half my expenses to
be deductible now because half my income
was not from ppp but the way that
amendment is worded it sounds like i
can't deduct any of my expenses
is that true or am i misunderstanding
something there
yeah um i i'm going to ask the dra to
confirm this but my understanding of the
usage of the term basis
has to do with the adjustments for
capital items and that sort of thing
so know that the first clause no
deduction
shall be allowed relates to the
deductions of current expense dot dot
dot
if the payment at the expense results in
forgiveness and the income associated
with forgiveness is excluded from gross
business income so i i believe the
answer to your question is no that's not
an issue we're conflating two things but
i would want the dra to confirm that
i've got that right
i definitely want to be sure yes thank
you
um carolyn can you weigh in
on both of those last uh conversations
sure i'll start with the last question
because that's the one that's fresh in
my mind
um so the
the first clause no deductions shall be
allowed no tax attribute shall be
adjusted and no basis
shall be adjusted for an expense
that is otherwise deductible so all
three items deductions tax attributes
and basis relate to expenses
a deduction is a deduction a tax
attribute is
for example a net operating loss which
is contributed to
through the use of expenses and basis
is again a capital contribution
that is reflected in expenses so
the limitation on deductions tax
attributes and basis adjustments relates
directly to expenses that would be
deductible
but will not be deductible because used
to qualify for forgiveness
so it's it's really it's not i guess in
your example it's
the 50 um
that were you were paid for with ppp and
not the 100
of your expenses that will be prohibited
representative or uh representative
spellsbury
yes if i may thank you mr chief i may
follow up so
so basically you are confirming that
that 50
of the expenses in my example would be
allowed to be deducted
correct
okay thank you
yes and i think that's consistent you
may recall during the hearing
uh the question or an answer exchange
came up where we were talking about
to the extent that i think this language
makes it clear it's only that only those
that qualified for the forgiveness
okay and then the conversation before
it was a specific question i can't
remember
myself
carolyn um yeah i think the question
before related to
whether there was a potential issue
with the expenses being incurred in one
year
and the forgiveness in a second year and
i think this is an area where
we'll all be helped by the testimony of
the cpas
tomorrow because
our expectation has been
that taxpayers were going to be treating
ppp loans as forgiven
um in the same year that the expenses
were incurred
and this is primarily due to some
guidance that the irs had previously
issued saying that taxpayers should
treat
ppp loans um as forgiven
if they reasonably believed that they
would be forgiven
in the following tax year but i think
taxpayers may have treated it
differently
may not have relied on that irs guidance
and so i think the
uh testimony will be helpful tomorrow
but ultimately i think
you probably have taxpayers doing a lot
of different things
um on their returns with these items of
income and expense
does that help everybody okay
thank you so what does that mean
yeah in response to that one i wanted to
make sure that
they the cpas
know that we'd like to know whether
they've
been the majority of them have been
forgiven yet or not it sounds like the
majority
haven't been forgiven yet because it was
so complicated for the banks to figure
out how to send something
to the sba and
in that case on
the question is going to be whether
on the forgiven loans are going to be
forgiven
by august which is the latest
that we can take this money back
to 21
or or whether we'll be dealing with
refunds in after august which would
have to go into 22.
and then i also wanted to to say to
representative genigean
that that the discussion that we just
had about
whether the 50 is okay or not
is in line 17 in the original bill and
also in the amendment
gross business income provided by
paragraph
one which was the ppp lines
okay i agree i think that very much
limits the identity of the specific
expenses in question okay
so the only other thing i'd like to do
here is uh carolyn
um you were gonna continue to do some
math for us
uh where does that all stand uh with
your team
sure um so
you had asked specifically to for us to
come up with the fiscal impact
of senate bill 3 presuming that
all ppp loans that the federal
government had appropriated are
ultimately
issued and we have done that analysis
and it's roughly
90 the fiscal impact is roughly 99
million
um and also based on the data from the
sba
it does in fact look like they will
ultimately
exhaust that appropriation by the end of
the month
okay so what you did is you did it to
the uh all
all loans went out all the the money
that we had to loan
uh or the the feds had to loan new
hampshire businesses
did occur correct right
and you use your same assumptions about
uh like it seems like it's
pretty close to 100 of being forgiven
is that correct so to date for those
um those applications that the sba has
processed
it's very close to a hundred percent
being forgiven
okay all right so
uh is there something in uh writing you
can send us to that effect
sure we can do that okay right
so you'll be joining us tomorrow correct
that's that's correct we'll be on
tomorrow
susan yeah mr chairman i think that
the problem is that a lot of the bank
paperwork for forgiveness hasn't gone
forward yet and we don't know what
percentage of that is never going to go
forward because they figured out they
wouldn't be
forgiven
but this is a good maximum
well it's the maximum amount that's
going to go out
so i'll be to be forgiven so
all right uh representative southworth
uh thank you i think we should use the
maximum um
i'm on the board of an agency who used
ppp
and every month we'd meet and we go
through the expenses with the bookkeeper
and the list from the state
and it really wasn't hard to tell yes
this counts no this doesn't
you know we had a separate line in our
budget for all of it and i just suspect
that a lot of businesses did that
because they wanted to be forgiven and
they wanted to be careful
right okay all right any more discussion
today on this
on this bill or the amendment
okay i would just and if we were in
debate mode there are a lot more things
that i could say i could refer back to
the discussion about
where other states stand income taxes
sales taxes the danish analog
and on and on but i would just like
everybody to really consider
even if we let sp3 go through unamended
would it really reach the targeted
beneficiaries
and and i think the closer you look at
it the money would go in all the wrong
directions
that would be skewed towards those who
don't need it and actually generated
profits
and they're only being asked to share
7.7 of that with
the people of new hampshire okay
those are good points uh all right
so uh well this is to be continued
tomorrow
i'm looking at the calendar here refresh
my memory that someone knows
is it is it may 27th that we have to
have everything voted out
i don't have my calendar in front of me
does anybody have a calendar handy to
yeah that's correct though so we've got
basically three weeks well let's call it
two and a half weeks
coming next week uh to
finalize this one all right so that's
what that one says i think norm i think
representative major wants to uh
start executing some of the other bills
uh and this will be held to the end
uh we'll probably continue to have
conversations on this
uh over the next couple of weeks so
before we break uh
for the day um uh any any other
discussion on
uh edith tucker it seems to me that it's
very important that
uh those who really fully understand all
the ins and outs
be able to come up with several examples
of businesses
mythical businesses perhaps but based on
what we know about businesses in new
hampshire and how they
had to deal with the pandemic and the
differences in
some really struggling and some not so
that
as we're talking about this with the
more general public
they can understand why it is
that there is this concern about
if we don't do this something like this
the money will go to the wrong not the
intended target
and i i think those words of
representative spillbrees
need some kind of examples so that
you know we apparently are going to have
two or two and a half weeks before
this will be voted on there is time for
some examples to be made up
to explain the difference
it's pretty theoretical otherwise and
there are a lot of people who are very
concerned who are in small businesses
well maybe we can have we can ask the
accountants to
maybe give us some examples tomorrow
um and maybe blinding the company that
they are
dealing with that they can give us a
sense of
how that math would work for some of
these but we can ask we can ask that
tomorrow
so you could even ask them whether they
agree with representative spillsbury
that
from their knowledge
the money is heading towards the wrong
group of people legitimate question to
ask
i think that would be a terrific
question right right
agreed well tomorrow's the right we have
an opportunity we got
two of these uh two of these fellows who
uh
i i've dealt with one of them in the
past he's very good
so um very knowledgeable on this whole
issue of
you know taxes and tax returns for
businesses uh representative army
thank you i just wanted to say that the
accountants that
have clients that are in the category
of uh of profiting a lot off of this
on are highly unlikely to think on their
clients
we might get good cases for
who who really suffers if we don't do
this
but i don't think we're going to get a
case for
for the ones above it that
is anything but a made up on
that i don't think we'll get them uh we
were
dealing with an issue sort of like the
sensitive
like this before and the only way we
could get some of the accountants to
talk
was was behind closed doors
you're probably right represent mommy
the problem also
uh to take off from uh representative
almi's point
is that we hear in hearings from those
who are
effectively advocating a position
and they often speak in generalizations
their examples don't get
pinned down and backed up with concrete
data
so the complaints tend to be i exhausted
all of my money
uh keeping my employees on the job i
struggled all year and i'm still
struggling
i closed my business temporarily and i'm
trying to regain momentum
but none of those people sound like they
have
taxable profits to worry about
you're probably right with 250 employees
did
okay any other comments or discussion on
this
all right so to be continued tomorrow uh
the only other thing i want to mention
is that we was briefly mentioned earlier
we we passed uh house bill 565
which was the study committee with the
senate
for charitable gaming uh that
that bill uh passed on
consent calendar uh
but then it no i guess they pulled it
off it wasn't on consent because then
they
they they passed it and then they tabled
it
uh now they have their version
which is one of the omnibus bills it's
senate bill 100
part four is
the language of the bill is identical
with the exception of
of a couple of things basically the
makeup of the
of the uh the committee
both say two senators and three three
uh representatives but the senate is
specific as to where they come from
uh which committees they come from so
uh we have to cover the hearing next
tuesday
it's at nine o'clock so not all of us
that they
we got a request from i think it's
legislative administration committee
so i did talk to representative ames
this morning who's who's uh
sponsored senate bill i mean a house
bill uh 565
and since then uh representative i did
talk to
representative guida i did get i did
track him down this morning
uh he's he doesn't have a feeling either
way on this
as to what what language we should
modify
uh but uh he suggested that i talk to
senator d'alessandro
which i will i will do uh see how quick
i can track him down
uh so uh and then i'll brief if i get
him today
i'll i'll brief everybody tomorrow uh
about this again
uh you know and it's the senate
representative ames his concern is that
he prefer to see this as a house bill
uh and that the odds are if it's a house
bill that the chair will probably be
from the house
uh and that uh we
better we probably be more comprehensive
uh being being this committee being run
by us
so um so but anyway i i'll be talking to
the
uh senator alessandro who's the prime
sponsor of
the senate version um just to see
how much flexibility is the reason i
want to do this now well first we have
to testify on
i mean the testimony is yes we we
already passed
this uh and do we want to do we want to
offer an amendment
to modify the makeup of of the committee
uh again they're very specific
my thought was that you know what the
compromise should be the senate picks
the people they want
and the house should pick the people we
want so
in terms of which committees they come
from so
um and i think i think senator
d'alessandro will agree to that
and uh so so that's just an update on
that one
um and if i could yes
i sat in on that hearing
and senator they tabled it because
on senator d'allesandro really wanted
to have someone from finance and someone
from ways and beans
on both
on on on both sides
senate and house and
i don't know why he he
really needed someone from finance as
well as
ways and means but that was that was his
main
ask and that's why they tabled it and i
think
that if we leave it as a as a house bill
and
and get it out of of the senate bill
so that it would they would have to take
it off the table which is what they're
planning on doing
if we do that uh then
um i think he'd probably put in an
amendment
to put that into that bill
on the floor which i mean that's fine
with us right i mean
if the senate wants to have one from
finance and one from uh
from ways and means fine but
we have to decide what we want our bill
is silent
6 565 is silent on what
what committees the members come from
other than the speaker appoints
it's just the speaker of points three
members of the house
uh uh do we all agree with that
that the three members should come from
ways and means
[Music]
what do we want somebody from finance i
don't know what
uh they don't deal with these things i
mean there's a ways of means that deals
with this
seems to me i think we really need
representative ames on this
and usually there are two republicans
so so we need we
want to do two republicans one democrat
yeah he would chime in just to chime in
here you know i think
either way it works out um we just want
to get the bill passed
and um the
if the the senate version faces
uncertainty because
here in the house not just because of
any tweaks we would like to make to
the part of it that's that's the bill
we're talking about but
um because it's part of a big omnibus
bill
and i have no idea i haven't looked
closely at that bill but
uh but may omnibus bills have not
fared that well at least some of them um
either
because they ran aground
in the house or the senate but also
because
this the governor has uh has
responded negatively to some in the past
last year
to omnibus bills that had some provision
in them that killed the whole thing
so there's this risk um associated with
being part of an omnibus bill and if
we're satisfied there's no risk there
then
there really is no difference between
the two situations
we do have a bill that's made it through
the house and the senate and has been
tabled on the senate side
and so it's in a great place to go
forward and the other thing i'd say is
that
i was there at the senate hearing too
and i didn't hear such a strong
uh point of view from
from senator d'alessandro i really don't
know whether
he if put to the test would
care that much about this maybe maybe he
does i don't know
well i'll take his pulse this afternoon
if i get him uh you know yeah
all right to be continued then so
all right any other business
so i think if i'm not mistaken i think
we start at 10 o'clock tomorrow
uh somebody correct me if i'm wrong okay
very good
so well have a good afternoon everybody
thank you patrick thank you
representative before you leave
did he leave um i have a conflict
tomorrow with labor
uh for i've got a 10 45 work session and
then i've got bills
to exec tomorrow afternoon or hearing to
do tomorrow afternoon
um can i pop into you and pop out and
then come back in
so that i can uh so i can take care of
the labor need over there
absolutely you know so yeah
you could be there the first 45 minutes
correct there at 10 45
is the is the um when we meet with the
department for
i believe it's department employment
security or somebody for a work session
yeah um we make most of the comments
from the accountants which you want to
hear
okay and i can i can follow up with
somebody if
for if i miss anything um uh however
much i miss
uh and then i've got to be back over
there in the afternoon for a hearing
session so
okay all right all right i just want you
to know that
okay sounds good thank you great
everybody
yes do you know anything about the
order of what's going to be done after
the accountants because i've got a
meeting that i really ought to go
to that starts at 11 and goes to 11 45.
i'm not sure what
other than the accountants that's the
only thing that nora mentioned to me in
terms of uh
outside yes and possibly some more
conversation with the dra
i don't think we have anybody else lined
up
for tomorrow so
okay i hate to miss any of it but
i'm i'm trying to figure out which
thanks
all right well you can watch the
recording not
the same but jenny were you recording
these
yes i was trying to say that earlier
okay you
so we're recording the work sessions as
well as the hero
all right very good everybody i just
want to know why edith is uh
stealing signs and putting him up behind
her
that's a fundraiser it's a charitable
donation
when you uh buy them
is that a 501 seat three years the 501c3
and i was treasurer of it for a while
and did file
annual reports with the secretary of
the charitable division oh that works